kim kardashian and kanye west are
showing a united front amid their
divorce
at the end of the day life is about
being happy
here's the former couple photographed
while grabbing lunch in malibu there's
kim entering the passenger seat of the
car while kanye is on the other side
seems like the exes were trying to keep
a low profile during their outing
together and even had security in tow
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through the
reunion between kim and kanye should
come as no surprise earlier this month
the reality star continued to show
support for her estranged husband as she
attended the listening party for kanye's
upcoming album donda in atlanta
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know what's going to top that
yay even got support from kim's sis
khloe kardashian her bestie jonathan
chebin and their four kids north saint
chicago and psalm
[Music]
and that support goes both ways earlier
this month kim gave kanye credit for
helping her be more confident i used to
care so much about being likable during
a candid chat with kristen bell and
monica padman on their podcast we are
supported by the skim's founder revealed
the valuable life lesson the outspoken
rapper taught her being in a
relationship with kanye for you know a
decade and someone that absolutely
didn't care about likability factor or
what any perception of him was as long
as he was true to himself
that taught me so much in the best way
kim and kanye seemed to be on good terms
after kim filed for divorce back in
february a source recently told et that
the couple has been co-parenting
successfully and both of them just want
what's best for the kids
and as for how the kids are doing well
the source says that they're also doing
great and that kim and kanye are
supportive of each other when it comes
to raising their little ones
[Music]
you